Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday; it's Question
Tuesday, the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters, let's get right to
it.
What's the cheesiest joke you know?
You know what kind of cheese can perform miracles?
Cheesus of Nazareth.
Who the eff is-
Wait, wait!
I got a better one.
What happened after the French cheese factory
exploded?
There was debris everywhere.
You got any new books coming?
I'm trying.
Hey, in TFiOS, did you name Isaac that because
his eyes are sick?
No.
Unfortunately, I'm not that punny, except
when it comes to cheese jokes.
I named Isaac after the guy in the Hebrew
Bible who also went blind.
How excited are you that the TFiOS DVD comes
out tomorrow?
Good news, friend.
Tomorrow is now today, and I am very excited
because, at last, people can see my brilliant
acting in the extended cut.
Will you ever appear in a movie of your books?
I have!
I had a cameo in The Fault in Our Stars movie,
but it got cut, because my screen presence
was too powerful.
They felt like people wouldn't be able to
pay attention to Hazel's love affair with
Augustus because they would be distracted
by the camera's love affair with me.
Any news about the Looking For Alaska or Paper
Towns movies?
So I don't know much about Looking For Alaska,
but Paper Towns looks like it is really really
going to happen, like, they hired a director,
the brilliant Jake Schreier who made Robot
and Frank.
The screenplay by the guys who wrote TFiOS
is amazing, my friend Nat Wolff is going to
play Q, and supposedly it's going to come
out on July 31, so I... it might actually
happen!
If you could change anything about your books,
what would it be?
Uh, the word "deadpan" appears like twelve
times in Looking for Alaska, which in retrospect
is probably eleven times too many.
How do I pass AP Chemistry?
Crash Course might help!
Who's your favorite Beatle?
What color would you be if you could be any
color?
I promise these were right next to each other
in my timeline!
John, Green!
Are oranges named after orange, or is orange
named after oranges?
The name of the fruit preceded the name of
the color by at least two hundred years.
Bananas or pineapple?
I guess we've reached the fruit portion of
Question Tuesday.
Bananas!
Will there be a nerdfighter meet-up soon?
There are location-specific nerdfighter group
all around the world, link in the doobly-doo,
there are lots and lots of gatherings, I've
always had a good time at them, check it out!
Why you love the metaphors?
I would argue that most humans love metaphors,
because so much human thinking is symbolic.
Like, we imagine a meningitis headache as
a "vice gripping our head".
And if we can imagine, like, particularly
original or compelling metaphors, it can help
people to imagine what we're feeling!
So good metaphors make my experiences more
real to you, and yours more real to me, which
is kind of what language is supposed to do,
right?
Can you make a metaphor using the word "slay"?
Now, this is not my area of expertise, but
I'm pretty sure the colloquial use of the
word "slay" is already metaphoric.
I mean, I don't think that new Taylor Swift
song actually killed you.
But we say that it "slayed" us, because the
experience of it was so awesome that now we
are... metaphorically dead.
I'm not saying it's a great metaphor, but
it is a metaphor!
Pizza or Ansel Elgort?
Ansel Elgort on pizza.
Ansel Elgort on pizza is not an acceptable
answer.
Hmm, then I'm going to go with Ansel Elgort
slathered in pizza.
Hey, review Hank's album.
It's Hank Green's best album to date, The
Perfect Strangers bring a punk rock energy
to Hank's quick-witted and lyric-driven songwriting.
I give it five out of five stars.
It's actually Henry's second-favorite album,
behind only the Phineas and Ferb Star Wars
album.
Aren't you and Hank supposed to do a punishment?
Well, I owe one.
Hank, what's my punishment?
How'd you decide on baby names?
We just stole our grandparents' names.
How many boys are in One Direction?
What is this, a quiz show?
There's Harry, and Niall, and Liam... ah...
Zayn!
Four?
Wait, NONE!
None!
There are no boys in One Direction, they are
all adults!
Hey, how many books can you balance on your
head?
S... seven, but not for very long!
Tell your son he's really cute.
Hey, Henry!
A stranger on the Internet says that you're
cute.
How do I get my three-year-old to eat anything
other than PBJ, pizza, and macaroni?
You can get your three-year-old to eat three
different foods?
Are you a wizard?!
What colour - unnecessary "u" - are your socks?
Many-colored happy socks!
Are signed posters really signed, or just
digitally?
When I say that something is signed, I mean
that I signed it, like with my hand, and a
pen.
Writing font?
Arial.
Thoughts on WheezyWaiter's latest video?
Awwwwww.
Favorite HP book and movie?
Four comma eight.
What's your favorite dinosaur?
Stegosaurus, because when I was a kid, paleontologists
thought that it had two brains, a head brain
and a butt brain.
And there was nothing in the world funnier
to me than the idea of a butt brain.
I have a question.
Mmm... that's not a question, Maureen, that's
a statement.
And so is this:
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.